in the last episode we explained how the
GCP global load balancer is able to
overflow traffic to back-end instant
scripts in the next closest region
during traffic spikes not only is this
more reliable for beyond treats growing
online business but it also gives dog
parents a better overall experience with
lower overall latency risks but the
beyond tree's leadership is hesitant and
they want to save cost in as many places
as possible they have a new claim to
fame after being featured on TV and are
new to serving online customers around
the world will global load balancing
give them a noticeable difference in
performance versus regional today we're
going to find that out
[Music]
[Applause]
what we'll be creating today is a simple
test web server running a CPU intensive
application that computes Mandelbrot
sets what our Mandelbrot sets a
Mandelbrot set is generated by
computational iteration which means to
repeat a process over and over again and
that will be a Python script we install
on our load test instances huh okay I'm
a treat well then measure Network
capacity using load testing tools on one
VM instance next we'll add a single
region load balancer with backends in
the same region and then measure the
response time and then let me guess
after that we will test the performance
when we scale the network to multiple
regions using global load balancing and
then compare that with the performance
using a single regional load balancer
yeah stimming ding exactly awesome I am
super excited let's do it let's go
through the ingredients yes here they
are you'll need load testing tools like
siege and a CT / siege simulates request
from a specified number of users so you
can see the capacity and expected
response times for an application HT t
perf sends a specific number of requests
per second regardless of whether
responses or errors are received it
tells you how applications respond to
load you also need a single virtual
machine instance back-end a single
region node balancer and a single region
managed instance group and finally a
global load balancer with multi regional
manage distance groups so start create a
V PC network for testing then define a
firewall rule to allow internal traffic
and allow SSH traffic to the V PC now
let's determine the serving capacity of
a single VM instance create a VM called
web server with 4 CPUs include a startup
script that installs the Mandelbrot
server create a firewall rule to allow
external access to it and then grab the
VM public IP address enter it in your
browser and you get the computed
Mandelbrot set then create a second VM
in the same zone called load test next
SSH into the load test instance and
install sage and HTT perf and try
request around 20 requests from for
parallel users you should get an output
of about five point zero five requests
per second using HTTP
run 500 requests at the read of four
requests per second and repeat it at
different rates like five seven and ten
requests per second you will see that
the system can handle five requests per
second and then drastically jumps in
response time and connection errors when
you have seven or ten connections per
second okay
now let's put a single region load
balancer in front with the manage
instance group in the same region once
you create the HTTP load balancer with
three VMs in the same region using a
managed instance template and health
checks you can run the same load tests
against the load balance system as a
load increased past serving capacity the
average and maximum request latency
increases sharply with ten requests per
second the average request latency is
close to 500 milliseconds but with 20
requests per second the latency is 5,000
requests per second it's a tenfold
increase your dog fans are not going to
be happy when you have a flash buy one
get one free sale on dog birthday cakes
now here's the real test let's set up a
global web server with HTTP load
balancing with backends deployed in
multiple regions once you create a
managed instance group in second region
with the maximum capacity of 10 RPS run
500 requests at 10 RPS and you will get
the results after the system stabilizes
the average response time is around 400
milliseconds at 10 RPS and a minor
increase to 700 milliseconds at 20 RPS
seems like the dystrophin C is a lot
less than the 5 thousand milliseconds
delay we saw with the regional load
balancer in our regional load balancer
test we saw the load balancer became
overloaded when traffic increased past
capacity this is what tends to happen
with typical on-premise load balancers
or when using the standard to your
network on regional HTTP load balancers
the request latency is increased by more
than 10x meanwhile using the global HTTP
load balancing setup let's your traffic
overflow to the next closest region with
available serving capacity you have
lower increase in end-user latency and a
better user experience meaning beyond
treat customers will still be able to
order pumpkin pie
Blastoise
it's peanut butter treats and carrot
cakes on national dog day
no full-service outages when traffic
spikes for more information about GCPs
global load balancing optimizing
application latency check out the
documentation in the link below that's
all for today on get cooking in cloud
here's hoping you are whipping up your
own capacity management with cloud load
balancers if you liked this video and
would like to see more such content
don't forget to Like and subscribe to
our Channel
[Music]